hey guys it's day one of III 2015 i'm
here at the lovely Rob hi and we just
saw tomb raider the newest one rise of
the Tomb Raider yeah that's right yeah
we saw we didn't actually get to play
the game did we know we watched a demo
we watched them how long was it them
about 10 minutes yeah it was a good 10
minutes but it was filled with two
different areas gameplay and cutscenes a
little bit of a sneak into the story and
from what I saw I mean there anyone
who's played the latest remake yeah Tomb
Raider it is completely on par yeah if
you remember in the last iteration how
she was you know just in a shipwreck and
she was just getting absolutely ruined
by nature this is this it's in the same
vein that's absolutely right yeah
they're going for the same idea they are
saying it's going to be more open world
right and we disputed that on in the
walking to into the this meeting we we
we thought we didn't really see that
much of it did way the open-world nature
no and they did this in the last one to
where they said it was you know kind of
an open world but by all means it is so
linear and everyone always probably not
something I always felt that I didn't
care for too much in the end the last
tomb raider was that you're going down
this path you're not going to avoid
going down this path there's like one
set way but then you can come back to it
anytime you want that was kind of their
version of an open world you can go
there later and yeah anyone and it's the
same in this one but you'll have to
fight the bad you will fight that bear
and it's a sweet scene actually yeah
it's really good but they did do they've
added a lot right so in this scene she's
kind of like getting hit by a snowstorm
and she's fighting weather but they've
done so much more to it there's
incredible wind that she's shivering and
shaking and she's breaking elements just
like she did in the last game you're
getting pieces of wood to make shift
things but in this one you can craft on
the fly you don't have to be at your
fire you can kind of attempt things at
your own pace right you kind of go I
Europe you can take your time lining up
your shots and things like that and
that's why we liked about it I thought
it was really cool absolutely in
addition to like that pacing that you
enjoy they did stick with the idea that
you can attack things in different ways
we saw a base camp with like four dudes
there was a hundred different ways you
could do it you could just go in and
shoot
everyone you could be stealthy though
what we saw was she shot an arrow which
distracted everyone made him walk off in
the different areas well she killed a
different guy she made a makeshift
maltov cocktail yes she did yeah the gas
can and elements she already had on her
which is really fascinating so if you
pick up items on the go you can craft
items out of them and then use them in
that current battle when I played it
before I was always with an arrow
because I loved stealthy kills that was
something I really enjoy doing and it
sounds like they're really going to
allow you to do that with more bow
upgrades Laura will also have upgrades
as well character progression just like
we saw on the last one yeah another
thing that's making a comeback is more
tombs and there's more additional tombs
in this one yeah I just that they look
these remote parts of the world right
and they really do feel like that they
may look strange exotic parts of the
world and it's just when you see them
for the first time in your kind of blown
away right oh there was this time in the
demo where the lights went out and you
knew you knew something bad was gonna
happen when the lights came back on
there are scorpions everywhere i'm
actually made me jump like I had a
little bit of a jump scare and that was
really cool so beautiful tombs it is a
gorgeous game I've also been told that
these worlds the open-world areas are
going to be three times bigger than
anything we've seen in the last game
yeah much bigger game it's beautiful
Laura looks great I mean I'm really
excited to see what else is going I
completely agree i'm reading so first
game that's awesome well for all the
latest on Tomb Raider and everything
else III 2015 be sure to stay tuned
gamespot com